if you're a fan of the Big Bang Theory
perhaps you can answer this simple
question for us what exactly is Benny's
last name
well we imagine you're totally stumped
right now that's because unlike the
other main characters penny doesn't
actually have a last name at least not a
last name we ever heard on the show sure
she became penny Hofstadter after she
married Leonard but her maiden name
still remains a big mystery even after
the season finale aired in May 2019 many
of us waited and waited but we never got
the big reveal and it's entirely likely
that we never will this omission
evidently wasn't an oversight at least
not through the entire run of the show
as it turns out the creative minds
behind the show made an executive
decision to leave Penny's surname an
unsolved mystery evidently unaware that
this is exactly the kind of thing that
keeps us awake at night Chuck Lorre the
co-creator of the Big Bang Theory once
handed that Penny's last name might be
Barrington but if that's true it was
certainly never mentioned on the program
or anywhere else for that matter so we
may have been trolling his fans as
executive producer Stephen Millar Oh
explained during a March 19 WonderCon
panel eventually we got nervous and
superstitious about giving her a last
name it will always be her married name
Hofstadter
he said something similar to vulture in
2013 what name could we possibly pick
that would be satisfying at this point
you know I don't think we will reveal it
we're kind of a superstitious lot here
we've made it this far without knowing
Kenny's last name I think we're good not
finding out and the plot thickens in
2017 actress Kaley Cuoco revealed that
she didn't even want to know Penny's
last name telling CBS it's kind of a
personal thing it feels like a jinx we
haven't said it for so long I feel like
if we said it the world will explode
Kyoko tauntingly goes on to reveal that
she has some idea about what Penny's
maiden name is but don't get too excited
because she never spills the beans
instead she clamps down and outright
refuses to share her top secret Intel
with us does she also think Penny's last
name is Barrington why the veil of
secrecy does penny have a last name
that's simply too embarrassing to say
out loud
for the love of God what is Penny's last
name it's really anyone's guess at this
point and it sounds like Kyoko is all
about keeping this burning pop-culture
mystery alive in fact at the wrap party
for the series finale in May 2019 she
even admitted I kind of love it
so many things are revealed in the last
few episodes you get a lot of satisfying
moments but I kind of loved that we'll
never know her last name could this
glaring omission have something to do
with how penny was conceived in the
first place as Newsweek reports she was
written into the pilot at the very last
minute an attempt to replace a character
named Katy who was originally intended
to be the girl living across the hall
from Sheldon and Leonard well test
audiences evidently really hated this
Katy and they thought a personality was
way too brash for the show whatever that
means in the context of the Big Bang
Theory nerdish to address these concerns
the writers started from scratch and
eventually created penny as a
replacement for Katy ku Elko had
originally auditioned for the part and
she was subsequently called back to
audition for penny spoiler alert
she totally landed the role since penny
was added into the show so late in the
game
perhaps the writers and creators totally
forgot to give her a last name hey it
happens and throughout the run of the
series
perhaps they simply never found the
right opportunity or right gag to make
the big reveal something memorable
much like the enduring popularity of The
Big Bang Theory this is one mystery we
may never get to the bottom of check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you
[Music]